welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today you
know one of the big things obviously
that's happened within the last week or
all of these abortion bans that have
been popping up all over the country we
had Georgia then we had the horrid one
in Alabama we're seeing them pop up in
Ohio and Missouri right now all over the
country these white men white Republican
men are trying to pass these laws to
restrict a woman's right to make
decisions about her own body and if she
dare make a decision about her own body
we're gonna throw her in prison if a
doctor dare perform one of these
scientific procedures they're also going
to go to prison if a man rapes a woman
and then she has to make the decision
because she got raped oh well he's going
to go to jail for less time than the
woman will and it's that extreme that
even Republicans now even some hardcore
pro-life do-or-die Republicans are
saying you just lost us 20/20 with your
crazy extreme laws some of these people
include Jonathan last who writes for the
conservative outlet the bulwark who said
recently that this law is going to drive
pro-choice fundraising for a decade it
will be overturned at the appellate
level it will almost certainly be denied
certification by the Supreme Court it
will then disappear into the pro-choice
direct mail machine where it will raise
tens of millions of dollars for the
groups who want unlimited unfettered
abortion on demand while I agree we
disagree excuse me with the fact that we
have some kind of abortion mill
procedure running here in the United
States I do agree with him now this is
not going to survive the appellate level
yes Trump has done a phenomenal job of
packing our courts here in the United
States but unfortunately due to the
extreme of these laws even those
hardcore Republican judges are not going
to be able to let this pass the Supreme
Court is going to have a hard time
agreeing to take the case if everything
was followed properly
along the appellate line Supreme Court
doesn't take many cases each year and
typically the ones that they do even the
ones that result in big decisions it's
because there was an argument along the
way that something was mishandled or
interpreted incorrectly in the lower
court's decisions they're not going to
be able to make that argument with this
one and therefore they're not gonna be
able to take up the case now that is a
best-case scenario by the way there's a
great chance they could just take it up
for the hell of it and suddenly overturn
Roe vs. Wade but Jonathan last is not
the only person there you also have
Jennifer Rubin who pointed out several
different Republicans in Congress
talking about the fact that these bills
are so bad it could cost them twenty
twenty you have House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy who said that I don't
even support this law because it has no
exceptions for incest and rape Trump
admitted that on Twitter the other day
he didn't say he didn't support these
laws but he said he's cool with the
exceptions for incest and rape then you
have eric erickson who said he's worried
that the abortion bans are gonna cost
Trump his reelection you have Pat
Robertson who said that this law
especially the Alabama one stands no
chance at the Supreme Court it's too
extreme it's going to lose when you've
lost Pat Robertson on the pro-life
bandwagon your party is in trouble and
they should be they deserve to be that's
the position they have put themselves in
by trying to launch and wage essentially
this culture war for decades here in the
United States this is what Republicans
have all been about and just like their
stances with climate change in evolution
it flies in the face of science as has
been pointed out by plenty of people
before me these abortion bans after six
weeks most women don't know they're
pregnant by six weeks they're not
showing they may have just missed their
periods but guess what sometimes those
are fickle and sometimes you can go six
weeks in between and not thing
anything of it most women don't even
know by that time you want to talk about
the heartbeat what you're talking about
are pulsating cells at that point this
is a zygote
it is not a viable fetus if it is
removed from the woman's body it cannot
survive on its own that's not a human
being
science tells us that but Republicans
aren't relying on science here they're
relying on what they consider to be
their interpretation of their faith this
is Christian Sharia law plain and simple
the party that constantly warned us for
the last eighteen years that Sharia law
was creeping into the United States well
guess what they were right it's just
that they were the ones creeping it
forward and it wasn't you know Muslim
law it was Christian law that is one
hundred percent the only reason why any
of these laws exists exist today because
they want a pander to their far right
allegedly Christian right base and now
even the Christian Right leaders like
Pat Robertson say this went too far
and we're all going to get screwed
because of it and nothing could be more
appropriate for the Republican Party
this is the party of small government
that suddenly believes that the
government should be regulating women's
bodies not men's bodies of course I mean
our insurance companies are still gonna
cover viagra you know likely depending
on your policy it'll probably cover a
vasectomy you know dudes you're totally
taken care of don't worry about it we
got you covered because we're also dudes
making the laws but women you can't be
trusted we don't know what you want to
do why you want to do this maybe you
should have thought about that before
you had sex because apparently only
women get to have sex there's no men
involved right where's the lectures for
the dudes where's the lectures for the
men maybe you should think before having
sex how about this you want to put these
restrictive abortion bans in place then
how about we have to it
attach a bill to every single one of
them that says that the man responsible
for it has to provide 100% financial aid
and help for that child for the first 18
years up to and including paying for
college should they go that route
oh and that also includes paying for all
prenatal care for women which for those
of you who've never had a child
typically goes well over $10,000 for a
typical nine to ten month pregnancy a
forty week pregnancy make the men pay
for it too
they're the ones who did this you can't
make a baby without a sperm and an egg
so why are we only trying to regulate
the eggs why are we trying to only
punish the people who have the eggs you
want to punish people punish both sides
sure it'll all be struck down by the
courts but I guarantee you it would make
people think a little bit more about how
one-sided these laws and the lectures
that accompany them truly are